Hales up guys my name is Jenna and I'm
here to answer one question what is
Cherno engine well channel engine is a
game engine it's an open-source game
engine that I'm making specifically for
Adam dare because there is a rule in lot
um there as you can see right now that
actually exempts you from writing all
your code basically the deal is if you
want to use other code that you've
already written like base code or like a
library you can as long as it's declared
and that it's basically open source and
anyone can see the code to it and as you
can imagine it's completely legal to do
that because people use game engines
like unity for example a lot I'd say
more than half of the people doing item
Dera using unity and that of course does
a lot of the work for you so it's
completely fair to write your own kind
of base library and basically a game
engine so that during the during the
time I guess or during the actual lot of
their competition you don't know waste
time doing that stuff because last time
I did let him dare I did Express that I
didn't really like the idea of spending
you know 50 or 50 percent or maybe even
more time on actually writing
boilerplate code or essentially just
code that that you know should have
already been written because it's the
same for every game and I still have to
write it whether whether I be doing
OpenGL or just normal Java rendering you
know like a pixel-based array you still
there's all this code that you have to
write so what I decided to do is make a
game engine right called Cherno and now
it was originally called Cherno engine
that's what it was called but after
popular request and because i came up
with the idea i renamed it to china ok
so the engine is called Cherno so like
Chennault's ear 0.1 right now so what it
is again it's a game engine you guys can
find it on github right now so
github.com 4/2 Cherno for slash Cherno
okay so the repository it's called
Cherno because that's the name of the
game engine and they'll be a link in the
description of course so there is I'm
telling I'm telling you all this apart
from the fact that you might want to
know is because of two reasons the first
reason is I'm live-streaming the
development of it pretty much completely
so whenever I'm developing it I'm
live-streaming it and you guys can see
those live streams on
twitch.tv 4/2 churn okay actually did
one last night where I started you know
from scratch basically and actually
started making the engine and I'll be
live-streaming all throughout the I
guess next two weeks sitting up until a
lot of death so um if you don't want to
miss a live stream follow me on twitter
my twitter account of course is right
over here so it's at the Cherno so
twitter compost the Cherno and as you
can see i was live-streaming last night
but the idea is follow me there because
i'll tweet out whenever i'm going live
and twitter twitter of course is the
best way to receive a like short updates
if you are unable to you know make it to
a live frame but you still want to say
it i'm not gonna be uploading it to
youtube because i play a lot of
copyrighted music during these streams
but if you go to my twitch channel and
your my profile on my past broadcasts
you'll actually sit because i am saving
them here so you can say this is the
stuff from love them they're 28 that's
actually last time i streamed to haven't
streamed in ages but here is the making
sure no engine framework this is like
three hours 26 minutes that's what it
what it did last night so you can watch
the entirety of that stream if you like
and that'll be all the development that
of course but yeah make sure that you
follow me on this as well because um
when I wrote whenever I go live I think
it'll either appear in your home page on
Twitch or it will send you an email
probably do both of those but yeah
that's the idea I don't know if they
send emails anymore they used to though
anyway so to get hub repository though
this engine is completely open-source
right it does have a license okay the
license is a general public license or a
GPL version 3 okay not version 2 that's
a bit of a difference but the point is
that this license you can read it it's
about about 674 lines
worth but the idea is that you guys are
free to develop any game you want using
this engine distribute it
I guess however you want as long as
credit is given to me so in other words
it's attributed that I actually wrote
the engine and I made it as well as you
have to enclose this same license with
your game so you cannot make a game and
make a closed source using this engine
it has to be if you if you're gonna make
a game using this engine it has
to be a GP GPL version 3 license with it
ok same license asked about that's the
idea that's the basis of it ok there's
obviously a lot more different terms but
that's really important that you guys
understand our license hmm ok great so
right so because I'm I'm making this not
only for myself to use and let them dare
but I also want you guys to use it in
Loddon day if you'd like because
obviously you know like as tons of you
guys who really want to jump into love
and dare but you kind of you're not sure
if you're ready or you're not sure if
you can maybe make again so this engine
is gonna help you out tremendously it's
gonna be very very simple to use us the
idea it's gonna take away the focus on
you know advanced rendering and actually
having to implement that stuff manually
as well as us sound level design Maps
and almost the other thing entities
fantasy frameworks that'll will be done
okay obviously it's not done yet it's
only been like again 3 out so I've spent
like 3 and a half hours on that so far
but um it's gonna have all those
features right and you'll be able to
jump in and make a game so I'm probably
gonna release um kind of videos in the
future once this engine gets a bit
up-to-date I'm probably gonna release
some videos as to I don't know if you
guys are interested again if you guys
are actually interested in this engine
and you want me to continue doing it and
then obviously a comment and a like on
this video is much appreciated but I'll
probably I'll probably release videos on
how to use the engine properly and solve
that but the point is the point is the
reason I'm showing you just get hub
repository is because I want you guys to
actually collaborate with me on this
right I do if you okay first of all you
can fork it I'm not gonna go over like a
get tutorial or a github tutorial I'm
how to use git and everything but the
point is for example let's just say
you're using this engine and you find an
error right and there's an error in mmm
let's just say the the display class
right there's like an error like right
over here or whatever what you guys can
actually do is you can open up an issue
you see there's like an issues tab here
you can actually create an issue here
right a new issue and you can describe
what the issue is you can assign file
stored as well of course or even better
what you guys can do is if you actually
on either the commit message here or the
four commits right you can choose to
commit less you say over here I there's
actually a lot of stuff that I did here
mom supports frightens ratio class
whatever bunch of stuff if you guys go
to the actual hash for that mmm more the
code for that whatever and you check you
check this out and you're like oh okay
here you added the let's find something
that could be a problem
ah not that this is pretty simple so far
but let's just say all this removes is
private right maybe make it protector
whatever you can actually leave a
comment over here right on that line
being like hey you know do this do that
or if you have general comments on the
commit you can leave them here and the
point is that you know you can open up
issues and you can be like oh here's a
bug here's here's a bug here's something
that didn't work out and saw that but
the point is that um you know together
we can collaborate we can make this
engine basically the best Java 2d kind
of pixel based engine that there is out
there and that's really the plan that's
the dream
so that's the idea right and you guys
are Corsa Freddy uses however you like
as long as you make that as long as you
attribute it to me and you um mmm give
the same license with whatever you
create with it but yeah that's the idea
all right
so if you guys are interested in more
videos on this if you guys are
interested in live streams make sure
that you keep your eye out on that I
will post a video to YouTube every time
I go live but Judy YouTube's publishing
and stuff you might not see it for like
the first hour that's why I'm
recommending you follow me you get on
twitch or Twitter but that's it alright
that's what the turnover engine is I'm
going to be spending a lot of time on it
in the next two weeks and and I hope you
guys will enjoy it as much as I do
good bye